I think that one of the things that we
enjoy the most as human beings is to
lose ourselves in an experience to find
ourselves in a situation in which the
gravity of the moment the weight of the
now is so powerful that we find
ourselves outside ourselves you become
what you behold so to speak so that our
neurotic inner critic right the voice in
our head that is nagging us anxious
about the future or saddened by the past
paralyzed by the past instead goes
silent and there is a grace in this
moment the weight of the now in all of
its gravity and splendor particularly in
a pre-configured
epic context can serve to purge you of
your angst this is a transformative
experience I mean I think when I come to
a place like this whenever I put myself
outside myself I am able to pierce the
veil I am able to see beyond my concerns
and my constraints and I connect with
something larger than myself it's
something that we can all relate to it's
something that we seek out right and
these moments these these these moments
do something to us that is is medicinal
right this is this is existential
medication we we address the existential
panic the ontological panic and we push
it out of our minds death goes from
being an imminent panic to a deferrable
abstraction thoughts of mortality
dissipate and we get to inhabit some
kind of eternal now immortality now as
we smash our sense of separateness in
temples of fragmentation in what Alan
Harrington formed called a form of
electronic Buddhism it doesn't matter if
it's the rave concert or Burning Man or
an opera theater or an IMAX screen or an
epic ocean the point being these vistas
these contexts these stages become
become rites of passage transformative
experiences moments of reconciliation we
slay the dragon we move forth and
and then the angst is gone at least
temporarily
you